We all have an inner dialogue inside our mind
- reminding yourself to pay your cellphone
bill, or even rehearsing a tough conversation
with a friend. But what if that voice becomes
voices that are out of your control?
Psychologist Julian Jaynes proposed a theory
that, not so long ago all humans heard voices
- created internally from the right hemisphere
of the brain, but perceived as external from
the left hemisphere (bicameralism). As a result
these voices were perceived as communication
from the gods. But around 1000 BC, with the
rise of modern consciousness, these voices
became recognized as our own. Some psychiatrists
believe that the brains of schizophrenic people
may revert to this state, and not recognize
some of their thoughts as their own.
Schizophrenia is a disease of the nervous
system, affecting approximately 1% of the
population. To be clear, schizophrenia is
not the same as having ‘multiple personality
disorder’. Symptoms often include hallucinations:
from seeing things that aren’t there, to
delusions such as a higher belief in conspiracy,
higher rates of depression, and most notably
hearing voices. Auditory hallucinations occur
in many disorders - from simple sounds to
words or names being called - but the voices
heard in schizophrenics are quite different.
They are often associated with their current
mental state, and can be quite hostile, accusing,
threatening or persecuting (58); ultimately
embodying many of their fears.
A 2006 study of over 3000 schizophrenic patients
found that genes related to immune function
may play a role - specifically the complement
component 4 or C4 genes. C4 is a gene involved
in trimming the synapses in the brain; for
example, teenage brains undergo a process
known as ‘synaptic pruning’ in which unused
connections are cut away to aid in our brains
efficiency. But in individuals with schizophrenia,
this C4 gene may be overactive and cut down
areas that are involved in planning, cognition
and thinking. Links have also made between
microbes in the gut - after all, the microbes
that live within us have also been shown to
modulate immune response and impact brain
development. One study found that lactic acid
bacteria were significantly more abundant
in people with schizophrenia, while another
found that the prevalence of lipid and glucose
abnormalities is much higher in patients with
schizophrenia.
And while diagnosing schizophrenia is primarily
based on behaviour and reported experiences,
research has found the cause to be a combination
of these genetic factors along with some environmental
stressors like growing up in an urbanized
area, minority group position, and even cannabis
use as THC can exaggerate psychotic response
in some individuals with genetic risk or developmental
trauma.
Currently, medication for schizophrenia mostly
focuses on combating hallucinations and delusions
but, unfortunately, 49.5% of schizophrenia
patients don’t end up taking their medicine.
This is why genetic research is so important
to combatting this disease. Of course, some
people can and do recover through a combination
of medication, counselling and support which
can greatly reduce the symptoms.
On AsapTHOUGHT we talk about how mental health
stigma is a serious issue in our culture and
the media. Many of us negatively contribute
to the stereotyping of mental illness without
even realizing it - so we break down 5 ways
we can all reduce mental health stigma right
now. Check it out with the link below.
And special thanks to audible for supporting
this episode to give you a free 30 day trial
at audible.com/asap. This week we wanted to
recommend the book “Schizophrenia: Understanding
Symptoms Diagnosis & Treatment” which tackles
much of the stigma tied to schizophrenia and
how it affects those with the condition. You
can get a free 30 day trial at audible.com/asap
and choose from a massive selection! We love
them as they are great when you’re on the
go.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!